[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez évidemment le principe
vous allez devoir élire le meilleur duo
hier à lons vote sur twitter évidemment
acheter pmp duo et le nom de celui ou de
celle que vous préférez alors le premier
le premier duo vos vidéos c'est un duo
mythique c'est un certain pascal obispo
tout à fait qu'ils chantent avec une
certaine n'a pas à saint pierre sont là
tous les deux alors bien sûr
wahou mais l'homme était bien des
lunettes pour les reconnaître qu aurait
encore ok c'est parti kenny lala
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
son
jeune avocat le niveau
lesage 6 janvier toujours toi
c'est que tu meurs je suis vous c'était
c'était pas mal alors vous voyez à ct
c'était pas très bon là aujourd'hui
c'est très mauvais voilà donc allez-y
les placer voila voila voila merci
nous allons venir ont dit vous des murs
vous l'avez de ninon je loue des nippes
hulu ou alou oui j'ai envie de vous
appeler louable allez-y vous appris
alors franchement qu'est-ce que j'en
avais pensé de ce nom mais il y en a une
qui chantait très bien quand même
est ce que c'est ce qu'elle chante bien
que c'est le physique qui rattrape la
voie non non on n'est plus là dessus
aujourd'hui c'est le talent pur qui
compte
d'accord eh bien on va rester dans le
talent on va s'installer alors là c c c
max et isabelle vous allez voir la c
j'ai encore rêvé d'elle
déjà il ya un problème dont je fais
partie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est fait pour ça
j'ai mal dormi l'upa pas vraiment
sept mois
[Musique]
en
cyr
[Musique]
ou c'est moi l'espoir
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
non alors je parce que j'ai pas ce que
vous en pensez
c'est là-bas et mellal là j'ai senti
d'abord une voix ah oui il me fibre une
chose non pas le chocolat quand même
aimé une voix et leur vous là je les
poids lourds alors là comme ça http
p.geo avec le nom déconnecte vous
préférez là je pense que vous avez pris
une bonne option pour remporter le
concours
oui bien sûr ridicule on était vraiment
dans l'interprétation et la petite
maison dans la prairie
merci merci voilà franche et franchement
c'était pas mal pas mal on est au niveau
des ricains là c'est pas mal hein wen
ont la joie non quand même pas en bon
d'accord on est et on était mieux on
était pas mal trouve que le para bons
rails et on a faim on a fait un vrai
effort ouais même sur le web et surtout
tout est en place tout était en place
quand même alors assis alors là on va
passer dans des confessions nocturnes
ok alors des versions régionales ont
l'adorent c'est c'est avec dit adams
fait là on a remplacé par jean michel
maire aidé les films wespiser alors il y
en a une qui est pas mal
l'autre on va voir ses parts
puisque tout est par trois à quelques
mois que je sens on ne voit qu'elle a
ses messages tout les gardes alors j'ai
un fils trésorerie pendant trois mois
[Musique]
de la nuit et là
j'ai pas fini je n'ai vu ensemble
je suis sûr que la société
cage était moindre aide
ça va
cg
j'étais parti g
on y voit la boulette
[Applaudissements]
pour vous c'est comme hier toute façon
quelle que soit la coutume n'a commencé
moi mais coûte et vaille
j'aimerais juste pour eux ce que j'ai on
a repéré ça le petit mouvement de rap
comme ça francofolies de la rochelle
ah oui c'est bon l apc à les y voilà
toi tu vas gagner et je tout cas y'a un
il ya un peu de travail qu'on a fait
c'est très bien quand même
on sent qu'ils ont fait les efforts oui
bon moment mais en même temps il ya un
avantage pour delphine de à la base mais
non faut pas penser comme ça benjamin
écoutez moi j'étais aux aveux c'est vrai
isabelle c'est vrai mais c'est pas cool
moi je trouvais ça normal
bon le duo suivant a alors là ce sont
deux grands artistes
la crème de la crème à la cc de best de
baisse ok royal au bar ok c'est céline
dion et garou aux punaises
mais là la gare où c'est en disant je
lisais dans le drôle de garou c'est théo
ouais j'ai lu un poème de gabarit et
dans leur annonce airbus et la berce
dans le rôle de céline dion c'est encore
pire dans le rôle de ces lions c'est
théo à y aller et dans l'autre de garros
et gerdi mallet musique
ce qui prend que ces piles ou jamais
c'est juste rosarini après les dangers
si tu crois que je t'oublie écoute on
vote encore aux portes de la nuit
ferment les yeux
comme si j'allais pris la mer
y sort tu la grand voile
et j'ai visé sous le vent
[Musique]
comme c'est joli de la terre
j'ai toujours aimé toi j'ai suivi d'un
[Musique]
bah oui c'est du droit d d'accord
d'accord merci beaucoup merci à rooney
c'est l'image est alors prêté aux éau
alias le tarmac
il ya il y avait quelque chose quand
même ouais mais celui-ci bloquer les
fonds sur le costume des intellectuels a
donc l'intérêt prise un peu tôt donc à
hénon personal d'accord revanche théo je
pense que là il a trouvé sa place dans
l'émission classe c'est possible pardon
en coulisses c'est vrai que j'étais très
impressionné bon merci j'ai vous avez
vous plus on verra le résultat dans
quelques temps le http diot avec le nom
des chroniqueurs derrière évidemment
nous c'est pourquoi pas ce que je dis
c'est franchement j'ai plus ou moins qu
il ya les villas balawi a comme encore
plus alors comment on peut l'oublier lui
non alors comme j'ai pas sans ma fille
je voulais vous rendre compte par vous
même de ce dont il s'agit c'est benoît
est un peu non éligible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le jour se lève
dans un
ce
à vue
[Musique]
il
com
dans un
tous
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
moi
[Musique]
un jour
ces femmes
de rien
le mois
com
[Musique]
ces 21èmes en tout dix ans déjà
je ne sais ce que je suis morte ou
vivante déjà ça qui est qui je ne sais
pas en tout cas pour être tout à fait
franc on se l'est 10,1
entre nous c'était pas mauvais à lestrem
découvrons ensemble quel est le meilleur
le meilleur duo de ce soir meilleur coup
alors ça va être
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à mon avis à mon avis ces gens mais
j'aime bien mais je veux non je pense
que le match je pense que le petit jetés
depuis qu'elle est magnifique c'est le
talent qui prima on le voit nous n'est
deuxième marche je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit le fun unique pantalon s'est
bien entendu